dylan bundy making his 11th start of the
year the era is just under six and a
half in 51 and a third inning there are
a bunch of strikeouts 53 strikeouts but
all the other numbers are kind of
against dylan he's looking for a
positive stride tonight there's the next
delivery and he gave him another slider
and that's chased and missed and uh out
on three pitches as murrayfield is down
swinging so carlos santana takes a
moment before he steps into the box
he gives that one a big ride to right
wong going back to the wall up against
it leaps keene wong hello
pulling it back into the yard
might have taken a home run away from
him long couldn't go any further back
his back was against the wall and
a good vertical leap right there and
that is out
number two for the royals 24 year old
jackson koar will make his first start
in the big leagues tonight against a
potent angels lineup that is averaging
five and a half runs per game at home
this year koar has had a terrific start
at triple a and was recently named the
aaa east pitcher of the month of may
that is fair
santana goes to the bag that'll help
jackson breathe a little easier two big
league pitches
and his first out one gone shohei ohtani
will be the next batter here's the next
delivery and that is way outside uh
change up misses so shohei walks on five
pitches angels have a one out base
runner and anthony rendon will be the
next hitter
into the dirt shohei will move up
there's the changeup so we try to throw
right on right change up and so far and
i think you're right kooby right on the
money with the fact that he is just
jacked up what happens on the payoff
it's on its way it's grounded through
the left side that's going to be a base
hitch oh hey otani's going to be waved
home he better hurry here comes the
throw he'll score
and an rbi hit by anthony rendon gives
the angels a one-nothing lead great
at-bat by anthony rindon cohart comes
back with a 97 mile an hour fastball but
this one catches the heart of the plate
rindone again hits it hard for now the
angels have runners at second and third
where a hit could mean two more runs
into center field hangs up
but not long enough to be caught it's an
rbi and the angels add another and they
lead it mad max keeps just
hitting and hitting and hitting since
getting healthy two to nothing and
moving up to second base is stassi in
the third wild pitch of the inning
high bouncing ball that will played
another run for the angels an rbi for
iglesias that will bring up the seventh
hitter here in the inning juan lagarus
lagarre lagaris into right field
down for a base hit the angels lead it
four to nothing oh a two out rbi feels
good and another base hit with the
runner in scoring position so jackson
koar's big league debut goes 39 pitches
and he gives up four runs in the bottom
of the first inning so irvin the long
time angel comes on with a runner at
first base and two down here is a swing
and a miss and wong is out and the
royals do get that final out of the
first inning but four run score
for the angels we're headed to inning
number two and salvi starts the second
inning well with a base hit to center
gutierrez the batter
bounced out to short
could be just what the doctor ordered it
was a
scalded baseball to iglesias once he got
a hold of it he fed it over to fletch
onto walsh for a double play two outs in
the inning and
solaire will be the next batter the next
pitcher swung on and hit high in the air
deep to left center field that's a way
back and that ball is gone jorge solaire
got a breaking ball and did not miss
home run number five for jorge
and the royals are on the scoreboard
trailing the angels four to one and it
looked like it hit michael taylor on the
left shoulder so he'll take first base
let's see if that solaire
home run inspires dozier and now dozier
lines it to left field how far will
taylor go upton takes him a while to get
it out of the corner here comes taylor
around third
and he will score so even after the
double play the royals score two and for
hunter dozier that puts an end to an o
for nine for the home third we go one
away in the bottom of the third you know
max
stassi he drove in one of the four runs
in the first the pitch from irvin
santana and a swing and a miss and a
high fastball and irvin santana has his
third strikeout on the night and now
he'll face iglesias pitch from the
veteran santana swing and a miss and a
slider away that's a strikeout the
fourth for irvin santana a one two three
third inning we go to the fourth the
garrison scoring position now for david
fletcher
david on 3-2 ground ball center field
base hit here comes lagarrez he will
score 5-2 angels fletch gets it done i
think fletch has to get a personalized
license plate let's have mr
r-i-s-p mr runners in scoring position
another base hit up the middle for
fletch we're headed to the fifth one out
single and nikki lopez will be the next
batter and he knows he needs two more
outs to have a chance to get a win here
tonight and he smacks this one to wall
she gloves it fires the second relay
back to first and that is a double play
to end the inning that one will be a
3-6-3
inning ending double play the bottom of
the fifth is next and that'll be a
two-out walk here's stassi who's had an
rbi single and is two times up
stassi right field well struck toward
the wall max god
wow that ball carry stassi boy is he
using that big part of the field base
hit rbi
first at bat two run home run right
center max dassey
who continues to entertain us 7-2 halos
we hit to the sixth inning with
merrifield facing dylan bundy
2-2 breaking ball really pulled the
string on that slower than slow
curveball maryfield goes down on strike
he doesn't strike out a whole lot but
dylan bunny has struck him out twice
tonight it's going to be an infield hit
for salvi and the royals have two on
with two out joe making the jog out
bundy had towed the rubber and was ready
to go to work and get a sign i think he
wanted to stay in the game chris
rodriguez getting ready to go to work
breaks his bat bounces it softly to
short flipped by iglesias over to
fletcher in time the inning is over go
to the seventh and so they're at the
corners now suddenly for the royals with
two down at whitmer field coming
up that is into left center field and
down dozier will score it's 7-3 so with
mirror field with two outs and two
strikes
picks up another rbi he has the most
rbis in the major leagues
among leadoff hitters so the batter is
there first baseman carlos santana who's
had one hit tonight that was his last
time up and the next delivery that's
lined into right field but right at
wrong he'll make the catch that was kind
of chess tie hardly had a move at all
here at the bottom of the eighth greg
holland comes out of the bullpen for k.c
and now a buck has just been called on
holland and being awarded home plate
will be the base runner from third max
stassi
angels get
as big a gift to run as you'll get right
there it's now eight to three
a wild pitch to third and then bach
you don't see too many blocks called
to begin with and then when you see one
call with a runner at third and that
allows the runner to score get it to the
ninth eight three angels james hoyt goes
to work batteries jorge solaire oh man
that knocked the helmet right off of his
head it looks like it it got him on the
top of the head
and knocked his helmet off right now he
is getting to his feet nick kenny
sprinted out
of the royals dug out and he is checking
solaire
hoyt didn't mean to do that just tell
you how easy it is and how the ball gets
away now the royals are down to their
final strike in the game
the angels victorious tonight as they
roll to a five-run win